hi this is presh talwalkar let's discuss
math problems where people are working
together to do a job the 1994 movie
little big league features one of these
problems
joe can paint a house in three hours
and his friend sam can paint the same
house in five hours how long will it
take if they paint the house together
the players come up with several wrong
answers by combining the numbers 3 and
5.
the most plausible answer is the average
of 4 hours
but this is clearly wrong because of
joke and paint house in three hours it
has to take them less than three hours
working together
the correct answer one of the players
gets to is one and seven eighths hour
but how did he get to this answer
we need to look at the rate of work
if joe can paint the house in three
hours then every hour he paints a third
of the house
which means he paints x over three of
the house in x hours
similarly sam will paint x over five of
the house in x hours
working together we add the rates of
work to get x over three plus x over
five equals one hundred percent
we can easily solve this equation to get
1 and 7 8 hour
more generally
we can think about people working at
different rates
and we can consider the time it takes
them to complete the job working
together the formula is a times b over a
plus b
please subscribe to my channel i make
videos on math and game theory you can
support me on patreon catch me on my
blog find your decisions
on twitter at preshellwalker and you can
get my books at amazon